at 39 our Newland mom is one of France's
youngest three-star chefs the head of
the kitchen at lasya chompin was in the
house he stepped into the ranks of the
elite just a few weeks ago he's known
for his classic and purist cuisine his
specialities include spiny lobster and
breast pigeon with radishes Elmo
remembers reading the renowned gourmet
guide even as a child grew up with
astronomy guides we read them a lot at
home as a child I even knew the names of
many three-star chefs by heart as a
youngster he used to watch his father
Jean Pierre in the kitchen Lamarr knew
then and there that he wanted to be a
chef I felt very close to my father he
took me with him everywhere the market
Bendtner and fishing in Patong he taught
me the importance of good ingredients
after training under several three-star
chefs
LeMond started working in his family's
restaurants in 1996 in 2001 he regained
the Michelin star his father had lost
after his father's death he took over at
the restaurant and hotel his second star
came in 2005 his recipe for success is
simple I don't even feel like it's worth
every morning I'm happy to get up and go
to the kitchen cooking is my passion I
give people my emotion and I get so much
back in October 2013 the gorneo guide
named Arnold mal Shaff of the year and
last February he received his third
Michelin star
foods critic lndra's has followed his
career over the years we wrote an
article about him when he still had two
stars and even then it was clear he'd
probably have a third one soon that was
more interesting for our readers because
it's easier to get a table in a two-star
restaurant everyone wants to go to a
three-star restaurant and it's much
pricier what makes our Nolan mall
special is the quality of his products
the perfectly cooked dishes and his
outstanding classical technique big
names like Alain Ducasse and pourable
Cruz brought French cuisine to the world
for many young Chefs they're role models
back then earning stars and other honors
played an important role and it still
does here in the renowned film d
culinary school in Paris students dream
of getting a star one day every year
some 200 young chefs come here from
abroad to get a taste of what French
cooking is all about French cuisine has
an excellent reputation that's in part
because of its long tradition and
because the French care a lot about food
it said they spend more money on food
and people in other countries France is
also an agricultural country and has a
large variety of products along with
many different kinds of wine and cheese
all of that plus the sophisticated
techniques have made French cuisine what
it is today
classes are taught in English a five
month intensive course costs nineteen
thousand euros despite the price tag
there's no bitter taste in the students
mouths the attention to detail the
technique the
flavors ously it's it's a it's very
specific French cuisine and so you can't
just you know open a book and follow the
instructions in the book we definitely
will get a different result than by
coming to Paris and actually working
with the most professional after
graduating the young chefs can become
apprentices at top French restaurants
including our new landlords
establishment now that he has his third
Michelin star less yet chompin woz is
always booked but he wants to keep the
luncheon price the same at 68 euros as
his way of saying thank you to his
longtime customers our restaurant has
had good times and bad times stood by us
and I'll never forget that if oil tea is
very important to me the young
three-star chef also serves a dish in
honor of his father lobster with
potatoes his father first came up with
the recipe in 1978 and now our Laurel
al-mal has given it a new twist it's a
special dish that he hopes will be a
mainstay on the menu
you